porsche's added a new gts to its cayman
range the first two-seater gts coupe to
hit the market and it's already the
flagship
the new cayman gts struts its stuff on
the circuit mallorca and true to the
cayman name alligators can move very
fast indeed
gts was made for both the racetrack and
the street gts stands for grand tourismo
sport which likes so many things with
porsche has a story behind it back in
1963 there was once a porsche 904 gts
race car that was street legal and that
was the concept behind the new cayman
gts it's ideally suited to both the
track and the street
the street six boxer engine of the new
top-of-the-line cayman is based on the
cayman s's 4.3 liter powerhouse
optimized fine tuning bumps its output
up to 250 kilowatts and adds 10 newton
meters of extra torque to make it 380.
the cayman gts with the porsche dual
clutch unit makes the sprint from 0 to
100 kilometers per hour and 4.6 seconds
and just breaks the 280 kilometer per
hour mark at maximum speed
reinhold points out that on paper the
difference between a cayman s and a
cayman gts isn't that much maybe a tenth
of a second off the acceleration time
and a few more kilometers per hour of
the top speed but in the driver's seat
especially on the track the little
differences tend to add up to one big
one
yes
the porsche active suspension management
sets the chassis 10 millimeters lower
and heightens agility
the optional porsche torque vectoring or
ptv gives the gts better handling the
ptv selectively breaks or locks the
differential on the inside wheel going
into curves to enhance the car's
steering precision and agility
former race car driver valtteri
describes the regular cayman s as a
perfect car now porsche has added a bit
more oomph to it with an extra 15
horsepower plus a slightly redesigned
interior
but for him
the decisive point is the sound inside
the car
at the press of a button drivers get the
look and feel of a real race car
the new cayman gts's cabin also strikes
the balance between the street and the
track the instruments are logically and
neatly arranged
and the surfaces are a joy to the touch
especially on the steering wheel
but it's the engine position that really
qualifies the cayman gts for the
racetrack
valtteri draws the comparison with
formula one the highest racing class
where the engine is mounted midway
between the axles to achieve the ideal
weight distribution
the disadvantage though is that it takes
up space in the cabin the engine sits
right behind the two seats so he says
there will always be fans of the 911
with its rear mounted engine and fans of
the mid engine the real high performance
sports cars
standard on the new gts is the sport
chrono package with stiffer mufflers and
a sport exhaust for the throaty racing
sound
the sound is as much a part of a porsche
as its body styling
for the new cayman gts reinhold
eisenhower coins the term everyday
sports car saying that gts is just as
good for city driving or zipping around
country roads or down the autobahn but
even without much converting it can also
be taken out on the racetrack and there
it does what porsche gts's have always
done best drive fast it's all the tweaks
and nips and tucks that make the
difference
porsche is asking more than 77 000 euros
for its all-purpose sports car in
germany over 10 000 euros more than for
the cayman s
that would pay for lots of concert
tickets but then the cayman gts comes
with its own orchestra in back for an
exhilarating sound and driving
experience
welcome to the big boys club with a new
grand santa fe hyundai has unveiled a
real biggie which can rival the likes of
audi q7 bmw x5 and the vw tour egg
the new version replaces the current top
model the
ix-55 despite all-wheel drive technology
the revamped santa fe isn't a real
off-road vehicle it's more like a roomy
suv
car tester sasha knops's hyundai hasn't
had much success in the off-road segment
the ix-55 didn't sell well and hyundai
is now hoping to regain lost ground the
new model is 4.91 meters long that's
22.5 centimeters longer than the old one
it has three rows of seats and can hold
up to seven passengers but how much
roomier is it really
at first glance the car looks chunky but
sleek thanks to a 10 centimeter long
wheelbase as well as a longer rear door
an extended rear window
in the front the new longer santa fe has
the trademark hyundai hexagonal radiator
grille with a fourth chrome bar
the headlights are outfitted with xenon
technology
the new 19-inch alloy wheels are
eye-catching too
tinted rear window panes lend the car an
air of mystery
the rear has two independent backlights
as well as two visible exhaust pipes
left and right
together they lend the santa fe an even
more powerful look
sasha says when the 4.91 meter long car
is really full visibility on all sides
is limited
despite a rear view camera it's hard to
see much in the back left or right from
the driver's seat
on the inside the korean car maker has
opted for upscale sophistication the
cockpit is modern and the materials and
finish are all high quality
drivers can opt for hill descent control
and parking aid as well as an off-track
warning system there's also an optional
large sliding roof
fold down the back seat and the trunk
has a volume of up to one thousand eight
hundred forty two leaders
the medicine
sasha says you can push back the back
rest so that there's more room in the
second row that makes for a comfier ride
and he says in winter you can add seat
warming
the third row of seats can easily be
folded flat this area has separate air
conditioning
now sasha's testing out the third row
it's not as comfortable as the front row
that's clear with the second row seats
in the upright position he can manage in
the back but sitting up that straight in
front isn't really comfortable nora's
being cramped in the back
whether you want to sit in the back or
not is one of the few decisions you can
make on your own with the santa fe the
rest just comes with the big size that
includes the 2.2 liter diesel engine
with a six-gear automatic transmission
and variable all-wheel drive
at 145 kilowatts it accelerates to 100
kilometers per hour in 10.3 seconds and
consumes 7.6 liters over 100 kilometers
when it comes to fittings there are two
packages style and premium with a
metallic finish a large sliding sunroof
and a tech package our test car has a
price tag of a bit over 53 000 euros
it's not a bad deal the basic version of
a bmw all-wheel drive x5 costs about 1
600 euros more
bmw has rolled out the 4 series grand
coupe as a smaller and more affordable
alternative to a 6 series sedan just
like its 2-door cousin the latest 4
series offers more dynamism and elegance
its market debut will feature a choice
of three gasoline and two diesel engines
the most economic model is the 418 d
with an output of 105 kilowatts and a
consumption of 4.5 liters of diesel over
100 kilometers
mercedes is getting on the on-road 4x4
bandwagon with its concept coupe suv
it's their answer to bmw's x6 the beefed
up front is reminiscent of the gla and
c-class but sleek lines dominate the
almost five meter long suv and there's a
powerful engine under the hood that's
definitely not looking to win any fuel
economy awards like the bmw x6 it's
intended to cater to customers in the us
and middle east
someday delivery vans won't be rumbling
around town they'll slip down
residential streets as quietly as mice
the battery-powered version of the
balingo van is the barlingo electric
situain's counting on it to improve
their sales figures in the utility
vehicle class
it reminds car testament of when he
drove bumper cars as a kid you step on
the gas which isn't really gas and the
car takes off and quickly gets up to
speed
as soon as you let off the pedal
the car slows down again just as quickly
the only difference to the bumper car
that he sees is the situation's cushion
suspension
and unlike a bumper car once the
burlingo is charged it can drive
anywhere anywhere within a range of some
170 kilometers
it has no exhaust pipes of course but
it's got plenty of space
depending on the body style the balingo
electric can carry up to 700 kilograms
mata says the new european driving cycle
assessment of fuel economy found a range
of 170 kilometers for the balingo but he
sees that as unrealistic particularly
because the assessment is structured in
a way that favors electric vehicles on
emissions ratings
in contrast to an internal combustion
engine which puts only about 30 percent
of its energy into propulsion an
electric motor uses ninety percent of
its energy to drive the car but when the
driver needs heat and winter the unit
consumes additional electric power
instead of making use of the engine heat
and that reduces the car's range in
winter dramatically
the bilingual electric was specifically
designed to meet the needs of commercial
buyers
an output of 49 kilowatts and a maximum
speed of some 110 kilometers an hour is
more than sufficient for making delivery
rounds in town citroen believes the
rated 170 kilometer range is more than
enough for commercial buyers
points out that the situation electric
is reserved for commercial buyers only
says commercial car buyers focus much
more on their needs and demands on an
electric vehicle the range for instance
they know their area of operation and
they have customers to serve in a
certain area so they'll be asking
exactly how many kilometers range it has
another factor is what use the
commercial operator will put the vehicle
to of course they'll need it for their
business but with private customers they
need a lot more flexibility they might
suddenly decide they want to take a
holiday in italy that would be tricky in
an electric van but somebody running a
business won't have those needs and
concerns
is made for stop and go driving for
noiseless emissions free and comfortable
delivery rounds in town
after the last stop for the day the van
can be plugged into an outlet and
recharged overnight
a complete charge takes about eight and
a half hours
a fast charge to eighty percent of
battery capacity can be done in half an
hour
it lists at almost twenty six thousand
euros plus a bit over six thousand euros
for the batteries
says the berlingo electric could be just
the ticket for business customers if
only the price weren't so steep
but thomas vidman is optimistic about
the future
he says as the car maker knows the
battery pack drives the price up but
otherwise they've got a good handle on
the technological aspect
there the production is streamlined and
cost effective
the battery pack is currently the
weakest point but once those go into
mass production the prices will start
dropping too
then the price gap between electric and
gasoline-powered cars will narrow today
though it's still an issue
and montes agrees if battery prices drop
in the coming years cars like the
balingo electric will be far more
attractive to small business owners and
deliveries around town
we're in monaco the principality in the
courthouse the rich and the beautiful
have long flocked to its shores
and it's also one of the more
spectacular venues for formula one
racing
but it's not just the latest models
you'll see speeding down the asphalt
circuit here since 1997 monaco has also
hosted series that features historic
motor cars which take place every two
years
the star of this year's event is this
auto union type c grand prix race car
from 1936 it puts out a phenomenal 520
horsepower with just a six liter engine
a five-speed transmission in the rear
and a differential located between the
engine and the rear axle power the rear
wheels
jackie x 8 time formula 1 champion and 6
time winner of the 24 hours of le mans
will be behind the wheel
thank you thank you
a lot of physical effort
there is no power steering assistance
like we used to have today or
brake assistance
so it's demanding and
i think it's a great privilege to drive
it especially around monaco
and it's also a track which is very
demanding for those who really compete
with not my case today but
if you imagine formula one today there
is nothing like it
you just can't flirt with the rails
it has to be accurate and no mistakes
allowed so
that makes the legend of
monaco
another thing that makes monaco so
special is the proximity of the
spectators to the racetrack
four-time formula one world champion
alain post is completely smitten with
the ambience here
the track is still the same you know
even if it's been some changes
still the same ambience same atmosphere
so you when you see the the cars the
drivers the old drivers or the mechanics
engineers and you know it's the old
history of
so in fact it looks like it's normal you
know but it's uh fantastic to see that
such nice cars you know i'm very
impressed about the all the drivers they
can be so i mean pushing out the cars
and being so fast and
for sure they have the respect of the
the cars but they also like to
to go at the maximum quite nice
the vintage cars champions of yesteryear
and the special flair monaco all
combined to make it a one-of-a-kind
event
but the historic race cars and legendary
racetrack also exerts its pull on the
younger generation
uh it's got to be up there as one of the
top events when else you get the chance
to race on such an iconic historic
circuit it's um
driving between the barriers with cars
like these that are so fast
and there what's fun with these cars as
well as they're um they still move
around a lot on the limit you've got
quite oversteer cars very low grip
surface being a road most of the time
it's fantastic
another racing legend james hunt is also
being honored here in the 1970s hunt was
nikki lauda's main rival he was formula
one world champion in 1976.
his son freddie hunt is here to keep his
father's memory alive
it was his first race in his last race
and as far as i'm aware he never
actually finished a race here i don't
know i don't think he did he didn't get
on with the circuit
vintage motor cars spanning 50 years of
racing history will compete in seven
different categories for a few hours the
spectators will take a journey back in
time into automotive history
but there's nothing outmoded or fussy
about the event the drivers give it all
they've got and push their cars to the
limit too
fortunately there's not much by way of
body contact today and the historic
beauties make it through unscathed
the auto union type c with jackie x also
hugs the curves as though time had stood
still the vintage race cars still put
out an impressive performance but as
german formula one winner gerhard verger
knows the race cars of old and today are
worlds apart when it comes to safety and
comfort he's glad not to be behind the
wheel
i'm sure i would because um i think when
you're young and you want race uh you
wouldn't care you know but uh if you
look today and if you would ask me or
even look to the other all from the
wrong cars
you won't have a try no thank you
to top it all off there's an award
ceremony a tradition at every racetrack
not just monte carlo
but here in monaco with real french
champagne victory tastes just a little
bit sweeter
you